is there any physical law that would
have precluded bitcoin's adoption in
1987 or earlier than this rise in the
last decade or something Bitcoin was the
first attempt that was successful so
they probably attempted a dozen two
dozen times before and they worked on
different elements of it for 10 to 20
even 30 years before it was bound to
happen at some point when you had a
critical mass of network computers
computational power encryption
algorithms and they just put all the
pieces together and that's what Bitcoin
was and then it took 10 years they
started a fire in cyberspace it took 10
years of the fire burning for it to get
big enough that it would work through
all of its risk factors and it would
mature enough that an institution would
be willing to actually put hundreds of
millions of dollars of capital on it
[Music]